bestellung bestellung erst ab einem
mindestbestellwert von 80 euro und die
lieferkosten betragen acht euro hier
ganz viele verschiedene prospekte
gesammelt also was soll man das so
nennen können
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video
ja ich habe mir natürlich euch geht es
gut heute starte ich mache aus meinem
wunderschönen alten kinderzimmer raus
das ist so ein geiles zimmer voll mit
dieser grauen wanderreiter es müsste mal
geben ohne spaß das ist einfach nur sein
zimmer sie haben ja mein bett und der
rest vom zimmer ist eigentlich so
komplett kommt sogar noch so ein radio
sofort zusammen gewürfelt hier so ein
paar alte riesch sachen und so die ich
mal getestet habe hier ist meine
autoschlüssel dass das einzig wichtige
was wir brauchen eine sonnenbrille
vielleicht und wird warst du noch ein ok
darum geht es wird aber gar nicht ich
lag gestern abend so gegen halb eins in
diesem bett und dachte mir okay morgen
was machst du morgen für ein video ich
habe zwar seine ganzen plant diesen
plänen nicht erstellt habe da geht auch
schon war ich habe schon 50 video ideen
oder so für die nächste zeit immer jeden
tag und 19 uhr schreibt euch das hinter
die ohren allerdings kann ich alle diese
videos meistens nur in köln drehen mit
kameramann
deswegen geht es dann morgen mit weiter
also heute fehlt und auch ein video für
hier und mir ist die geniale idee
gekommen weil ich ja öfter schon mal
irgendwas mit lieferservice gemacht
haben vergleich doch einfach mal so ein
bisschen lieferservice in großstadt mit
lieferservice auf dem dorf das war so
ein gedankenblitz und erstmal dann auch
okay warte mal also was soll ich da
jetzt vergleich nicht meine pizza gibt
es überall
kein plan dann habe ich aber gedacht ich
habe bestimmt viele zuschauer die in der
großstadt leben und gar nicht wissen wie
so ein lieferservice auf dem dorf
eigentlich aussieht also man muss halt
sagen wir hier auf dem dorf ich sag
jetzt einfach mal dorf ich wohne in der
kleinstadt 20.000 einwohner wir haben
nicht die chance rund um die uhr
irgendwas zu essen zu bestellen
bei uns herrschen andere regeln und
darum geht es heute also alle leute vom
dorf können wahrscheinlich mitfühlen wie
es mir ergehen wird ja und alle leute in
der großstadt ihr werdet euch noch
umgucken wir werden heute was bestellen
ich werde euch das mal zeigen wie das
hier eigentlich funktioniert weil ich
kann mir vorstellen dass viele das gar
nicht wissen man muss sagen gerade ist
es leider 14.30 das heißt jeder
lieferservice in der umgebung hat zu
machen heute pause wollen sich nicht
lohnt es wird schon mal kurz auf die
andere kam und ich zeige euch was ich
meine
bis gleich okay leute was geht hier bin
ich ich muss mal kurz die lieferando app
aufs handy
weil ich habe irgendwie gar nicht und
dann zeige ich euch mal was wirklich
krass wie so ein liefersystem in der
großstadt aussieht ist ja natürlich ganz
klar du kannst rund um die uhr
eigentlich bestellen zumindest in köln
wir können immer eine pizza bestellen
wirklich rund um die uhr auch um drei
uhr morgens die schmeckt dann zwar nicht
so gut weil die halt keine konkurrenz
haben die meisten aber das geht ich habe
ja auch viele videos von darüber gemacht
wenn sich immer noch heute fragen okay
wie war das doch ein großstadt das wird
wurde nicht thematisiert ja also ich
schon eben gesagt wir haben jetzt 14 uhr
46 und in köln
also wieso wirst du kannst bestellen was
du willst es hat eigentlich alles offen
die liste ist unendlich lang ok ich muss
auch sagen ich habe hier noch nie also
jetzt hier weil meine eltern auch dorf
jeden was bei lieferando bestellt oder
irgendeinem anderen online anbieter weil
ich gar nicht dachte dass da überhaupt
irgendwann gibt da über diese app
liefert ich gebe jetzt wenn man
aktuellen standort an
und wir haben sogar neuen restaurants
die hin liefern wird und das hat mich
sehr gewundert man dann ist mir aber
eine sache aufgefallen weil ich
eigentlich weiß dass jetzt gerade in
dieser zeit hier in der stadt jedes
restaurant zu halten du kannst weil die
vereine bestellen allerdings kommt dann
hier so was raus ja louis pizza express
liefert aus keine ahnung wo und wir
haben passt auf haltet euch fest
bestellung bestellung erst ab einem
mindestbestellwert von 80 euro und die
lieferkosten betragen 8 euro in köln
betragen die meistens 0 und der
mindestbestellwert liegt so bei 910 euro
und man kann es verstehen weil dieses
restaurant ist ungefähr so 30 kilometer
von hier weg ist aber das ist halt das
problem war doch eine pizzeria da kann
man bestellen ab 35 euro
lieferkosten und sogar gratis aber
trotzdem etwa 530 euro da muss ich einen
großen beschwören hof gehen also das ist
halt erstmal das erste problem du kannst
dich rund um die uhrzeit bestellen
wir müssen jetzt noch bis 17 uhr warten
glaube ich und dann kann ich bestellen
allerdings nicht per app oder sonst hast
du musst entweder vorbeifahren und das
dort persönlich abholen oder bewusst bin
ich mir in köln irgendwie gar nicht mehr
vorstellen irgendwo anrufen und sie
haben eine bestellung durch zu geben das
heißt wir warten jetzt noch zwei stunden
und zehn minuten und dann sehen wir uns
wieder und dann zeige ich euch mal wie
man auf dem dorf bestellt sechseinhalb
stunden später okay leute
wir haben jetzt viertel nach fünf also
genau die passende zeit die meisten
machen hier halt um 17 uhr irgendwie
wieder auf die sonne ball hat auf jeden
fall und ich zeige euch jetzt mal
schnell wie das geht
oder wie es halt auch ein dorf
funktioniert ich muss natürlich auch
sagen so ich habe hier auch so ein stamm
die service wenn ich irgendwann mal was
bestelle dann rufe ich immer daran und
bestellen eigentlich auch immer das
gleiche aber wir haben über die jahre
hier ganz viele verschiedene prospekte
gesammelt also dass man das so nennen
kann
das ist ganz üblich dann steht dann hier
so die telefonnummer wo man anrufen kann
und hier haben wir dann auch eine
speisekarte die sogar relativ
ausführlich ist also würde ich gar nicht
mal sagen dass die italienischen
restaurants oder so in köln
da mehr auswahl haben
hallo ich würde gerne das bestellen
liefern und zwar eine spaghetti pizza
margherita wie lange dauert so alles
klar
ok ja und das war's dann auch schon
also ich habe das noch nie anders
gemacht hier das ist immer schon so das
gehört einfach hier wenn man was
bestellt dazu dass man anruft und nicht
irgendwie internet und so also da leben
wir hier einfach noch nicht in dieser
zeitzone und wenn ich mir dann hier
diese prospekte angucke das ist halt
wirklich einfach so voll 2010
wahrscheinlich werde ich auch oft einen
kommentar lesen was zum fakt ist eine
spaghetti pizza
das ist einfach das geilste und das gibt
es gar nicht überall in deutschland ich
war auch schon also zum beispiel in köln
wenn ich das nicht die kochen als
spaghetti klappt ihn noch auf eine pizza
drauf dann kommt dann auch so eine geile
soße drauf und das ist einfach das heft
liegt probiert es mal aus wenn dir das
noch nicht kennt ich kann natürlich nur
bezahlen paypal oder so geht nicht und
es gibt natürlich auch nicht diese xxl
liefer leben wo halt alles gemacht wird
mexikanisch italienisch türkisch
amerikanisch so einfach voll auf masse
hier kann es eigentlich überall
bestellen und das ist immer gut
es gibt zwar nicht so viel auswahl aber
es ist gut und wir warten jetzt mal auf
mein essen weil dann zeige ich euch
gleich mal die spaghetti bezahlt
[Musik]
120 gespielt
ich weiß auch nicht vielleicht habe mich
verhört und die hat gesagt eine stunde
und 15 minuten
ich habe den film nachgestellt und wir
haben jetzt schon fit for 7
[Musik]
aber leute was man auch sagen muss in
köln wenn ich zwei pizzen bestelle ich
bezahle eigentlich maximal elf euro für
der normale margarita oder salami zum
beispiel und jemand 1350 also ein
bisschen teurer arbeit nicht so schlimm
dafür weiß ich dass es gut schmeckt und
jetzt gebt euch die spaghetti pizza
alters wirklich die heftigste pizza das
ist so schade dass sie so selten gibt
wenn ich dich schon mal probiert habt
geht man jetzt noch nach oben dann seid
ihr die heftigsten und abonniert main
kanal um folgende auf instagram okay das
recht so
allein schon der geruch davon das ist
wirklich mal leute gebt euch das mal
bitte danke
da ist nicht nur dass sie doch einfach
nur extrem gut aus ich wohne jetzt schon
zwei jahren in köln und ich habe
wirklich schon bei vielen plätzen
bestellt und ich habe auch mittlerweile
eine gefunden die echt richtig gut ist
also mit der welt voll zufrieden was man
aber auch sagen muss die kommt einfach
nicht an dieser vom dorf also das ist
wirklich eine absolut krank wurde ich
hab hier noch eine andere pizza bestellt
damit ich auch den mindestbestellwert
komme die schenke ich jetzt meine mutter
oder mein ahnung irgendwem der gleich
kommt also essen kann ich dir jetzt
alleine das muss ich ja nicht zeigen
deswegen würde ich auch sagen mehr
roary auch zu dem thema nicht sagen
großstadt lieferservice hat seine
vorteile dorf aber auf jeden fall auch
wo das ganze so ein bisschen familiärer
ist und er hat noch so ein bisschen
zurückgeblieben halt ich hoffe für die
leute die aus der stadt kommen war das
video ganz cool ich kann sich überhaupt
nicht einschätzen ich hatte einfach
diese idee habt jetzt umgesetzt
vielleicht kommt auch ein bisschen
komisch rüber kein plan auf jeden fall
bis morgen soll es wieder ein video was
professioneller und cooler wir glaube
ich jeden tag
aktive die glocke abonniert den kanal
jack ma instagram da kommen auch viele
fotos auch fast jeden tag ich bin so
aktiv zu 2 und zum abschluss zeige ich
euch nochmal dieses geniale meisterwerk
also wert heißt keinen hunger hat leute
ohne spaß heftige begrüße gehen raus an
die pizzeria hat weiß dass irgendwer von
euch seht ihr seid die die besten und
ich beende dieses video jetzt mit diesem
blick auf die pizza schreibt mir gerne
weitere ideen für weitere essens videos
in die kommentare
und wir sehen uns morgen um 19 uhr